avec Annie va reporter de guerre
indépendant de bonjour Anne oui bonjour
Raphaël et Go Thierry binsky chroniqueur
international ici à France 24
l'Europe à la manœuvre en Ukraine les 27
vont former des soldats Ukrainiens 15000
au total en plus de fournir des armes
des systèmes de défense entière et
notamment et il faut dire que la Russie
s'acharne désormais par les airs nous
vous bombardements sur des sites
énergétiques emploi de drones kamikaze
aussi contre la capitale qui est des
drones de fabrication iranienne écouter
ce qu'on dit le porte-parole de l'armée
de la ukrainienne
selon notre décompte préliminaire de 85
à 96% de ces drones ont été détruits par
notre défense aérienne et nos autres
forces de défense incluant nos troupeau
au sol Gautier
Ukraine les moyens de faire face à ses
attaques alors compte tenu de ce que
l'Ukraine possède aujourd'hui elle a les
moyens encore de s'opposer ou de
résister à ce type d'attaque mais il
semblerait qu'elle soit juste au dernier
cran de ses possibilités parce que des
drones kamikazes ont finalement
y paraît oui comment il paraît malgré
tout alors c'est l'emploi de notamment à
parler pardonnez-moi mais de l'aviation
japonaise guerre mondiale qui a
déclenché l'usage de la bombe atomique
par les Américains totalement mais là
dans ce cas de figure si vous voulez le
la disposition de des batteries
anti-aériennes et des instruments
antidrone de l'armée ukrainienne leur
permet encore de résister
quantitativement le problème c'est que
d'une part la portée des missiles alors
Shahid qui sont de fabrication iranienne
sont probablement de pouvoir pénétrer
beaucoup plus au sein du territoire
ukrainien et deuxièmement il y a la
difficulté pour les Ukrainiens de faire
face à un type de bombardement en masse
de ces de ces missiles de ces drones
pardon et si la Russie décide d'employer
encore plus alors tout le dépend aussi
des fonds dans la Russie disposent et si
elle décide d'employer encore plus ces
drones il y aura un moment où les
défenses ukrainiennes seront saturées et
en fonction de ça alors on en reparlera
peut-être tout à l'heure il y a quelque
chose si vous voulez qui est de l'ordre
du marchandage avec l'Iran qui dit bah
écoutez nous peut-être qu'on pourra
arrêter de livrer ces choses là mais
vous arrêtez de nous embêter avec les
femmes iraniennes donc il y a quelque
chose qui relève un peu de ce
marchandage là quel est le but recherché
par la Russie un terroriser les
populations
ah oui tout à fait je crois que c'est
les images depuis l'apparition de ces
grandes kamikazes sont absolument
stupéfiantes c'est-à-dire on est passé
de d'une guerre de des tranchées puisque
c'était véritablement ça depuis le début
depuis le 24 février on est quand même
dans une guerre de territoire avec des
tranchées élaborés construits bétonner
de part et d'autre certaines depuis 2014
etc et là on est dans la guerre du 21e
siècle avec ses nouveaux appareils qui
font fureur qui provoquent la terreur
qui font paraît-il un bruit épouvantable
de de de moteurs qui volent très bas qui
effectivement sont très visibles de la
part de la population et puis ces images
vous les avez vu ou je crois que de de
policiers
Ukrainiens qui depuis le trottoir depuis
là où ils sont prennent leurs armes de
poing et tirent sur ces drones c'était
il y a même des instructions sur les
médias sociaux
Ukrainiens sur comment on peut essayer
d'avoir ces drones kamikazes en tirant
en avant de la trajectoire etc etc donc
la capacité d'adaptation non seulement
des militaires Ukrainiens mais surtout
de la population ukrainienne à cette
nouvelle façon de faire la guerre mais
on ne sait pas on ne sait pas combien de
temps ça va durer parce que la Russie a
combien de drones qu'elle peut comme ça
envoyer à l'abattoir d'une certaine
manière non pas dit officiellement c'est
bien là le problème que c'était eux qui
les envoyer donc pour le moment on est
dans le brouillard de la guerre mais le
fait est que la Russie pour le moment
dans les jours derniers on ne sait pas
pour combien de jours encore
auraient sensiblement changé de
stratégie militaire elle s'adapte et les
Ukrainiens s'adapte en face serait-ce
parce qu'il y a un manque de munitions
plus classique serait-ce parce que venir
Poutine voudrait aboutir à quelque chose
d'autre qui serait quand même
un cessez le feu temporaire qui lui
permettrait de se regrouper et de faire
une contre-offensive plus tard après les
fêtes et après la mauvaise météo on ne
sait pas en qui FAQ effectivement l'Iran
de fournir ces drones elle réclament des
sanctions à l'Union européenne Gauthier
au moment même à outé errant se met à
dos ces interlocuteurs européens vous
l'avez dit pour ça répression ça ajoute
à la complexité du conflit pas tellement
à la complexité mais à la résolution
d'une partie de ce conflit c'est-à-dire
que le problème de Téhéran à chaque fois
qu'elle soit avec le nucléaire ou
d'autres domaines c'est de dire on va
maintenir une pression laquelle est très
importante jusqu'ici pour l'intérieur
iranien c'est-à-dire pour la société
iranienne qui jusqu'ici se fédérer
derrière cette pression alors on ne va
pas trop loin mais on la pousse quand
même en disant vous voyez si vous
occidentaux vous allez trop loin on peut
dépasser et c'est un peu pareil c'est
pour ça que je parlais de marchandage
tout à l'heure c'est un peu pareil avec
cette affaire parce que je suis pas
persuadé que les Iraniens et grand
intérêt à armer les Russes parce que au
fond les choses se déroulent ailleurs en
Syrie on l'a bien vu qu'il y avait été
un camp d'entraînement quelque sorte
pour les pour les Russes mais parce que
il y a cette possibilité non seulement
de vendre mais aussi de dire à la Russie
parce qu'il y a toujours des rivalités
nous sommes là aussi nous iraniens et
vous voyez bien vous qui êtes alors soit
en but à des manques de munitions soit
tout simplement de fond pour ce pays des
armes soit parce que les usines en
Russie sont un peu grippés et bien nous
on peut venir en rescousse mais
attention on a ce pouvoir de vous
délivrer d'un étau ukrainien et puis si
vous ne voulez pas vous disons être
beaucoup plus proche de nous on peut
arrêter ces livraisons mais je crois pas
que ça soit si vous voulez que ça
complexifie le le conflit ça le rend
simplement plus perméable aux ingérences
extérieures auxquelles on ne pensait pas
forcément au début un ayant n'est pas
mécontent d'apparaître finalement comme
un protagoniste de ce conflit pour faire
valoir un peu un rapport de force avec
les Occidentaux après vous sans aucun
doute mais moi ce qui ce qui m'importe
davantage c'est j'ai l'impression que on
est un peu dans une impasse pour le
moment dans ce conflit avec justement
l'utilisation de avec justement le fait
que il n'y a toujours pas de victoire
militaire claire d'un côté ou de l'autre
c'est à dire après cette grande
contrefensive ukrainienne qui a provoqué
du côté russe une débandade mais qui
l'armée russe continue à tenir ses
positions
elle voulait dire Poutine que vous
l'avez entendu à décréter que la
mobilisation serait terminée dans 15
jours pourquoi la t-il décrété parce
qu'il craint que si la mobilisation
continue et bien il y est toujours et
encore et même plus encore davantage de
tension dans son pays et il y a eu il y
a eu samedi une fusillade très
importante quand même à belgorodes dans
sur un terrain d'entraînement donc en
territoire russe proximité de la
frontière
ukrainienne
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ça a d'abord
ça a été le ministère de la Défense à
dès le lendemain avouer qu'il s'était
passé quelque chose qui est déjà une
information parce que d'habitude il le
cache il y aurait eu 11 morts d'autres
médias indépendants anti-cremlin disent
qu'il en a eu 22 et c'est une fusillade
entre militaires russe qui allait partir
sur le front donc c'est très mauvais
signe et ça serait entre des volontaires
pas entre des volontaires et des
conscrits mais entre des volontaires
même et ça serait trois volontaires
d'origine
qui se sont portés volontaires pour
participer à ce conflit qui aurait
ouvert le feu sur d'autres volontaires
suite à une dispute parce qu'un
commandant avait décrété qu'il
s'agissait d'une guerre sainte ce à quoi
les Tadji ont répondu que non la guerre
sainte c'est entre musulmans et non
musulmans et c'est pas ça la guerre
Ukraine enfin il y a pas de certitude
sur ce que je dis là mais c'est
différentes sources que j'ai lu ce que
ça veut dire ça veut dire que en Russie
aujourd'hui au niveau de cette
mobilisation et au niveau de l'ambiance
pour aller sur le front c'est
extrêmement dangereux et sur le fil
c'est pas la ferveur qu'on observe côté
ukrainien absolument pas mais la Russie
ne défend rien la Russie attaque et
surtout si je peux permettre juste il y
a un élément qui est quand même constant
dans ce genre d'opération je pensais à
l'Afghanistan et à la Géorgie c'est que
les Russes qui prétendent avoir le
leadership envoie toujours en priorité
des soldats qui viennent qui sont sur
représentés proportionnellement on a
bien vu qu'au début c'était des gens qui
étaient bourrées c'est-à-dire une Russe
non russe et donc à chaque fois on
signale la suprématie la primauté slave
parce que c'est ça aussi et au final ce
sont plus que proposent un Allemand des
autres personnes qui vont se situer pour
terminer là-dessus c'est très
intéressant ce que dit Gauthier parce
que justement vous rappelez-vous il y a
quelques semaines c'est au d'aggestant
qu'on a eu le plus de confrontation
entre des mères de soldats qui disaient
non face aux forces de sécurité russe
qui disait nous nous n'appartenons pas
au monde russe donc nous ne pouvons pas
envoyer nos enfants défendent ce monde
russe et ça c'est la première fois que
des mots comme ça sont prononcés dans
l'espace public russe donc c'est très
très important ce qu'ils ont en train de
se passer ça peut être potentiellement
dangereux pour l'unité même de la de
Russie je précise que vous vous rendez
dans les prochains jours en Russie
justement et vous nous ferez vivre sur
place et l'évolution de la situation
puisque il y a il faut dire assez peu de
compte rendu de la situation sur place
là-bas vu de Russie après ma xedong et
denxiaoping la Chine s'apprêtait à
entrer définitivement dans les inping
après le grand puis le petit quel
timonier sera celui qui brille un
troisième mandat inédit à la tête du
Parti communiste chinois le PCC qui
tient son congrès donnera sa réponse
mais déjà à la Chine montre des signes
d'embarras face aux chiffres de la
croissance vraisemblablement en berne
ils étaient censés être publier ce matin
et seront finalement reportés histoire
de ne pas trop ternir les festivités
écoutez chez Jinping justifier la mise
sous cloche de l'économie chinoise par
la politique dite de zéro covid
nous avons placé la population et les
vies humaines au-dessus de tout
nous avons persévéré avec ténacité dans
une politique dynamique de zéro covid en
lançant une guerre totale très populaire
pour arrêter la propagation du virus
voilà résultat une croissance divisée
par deux on parle de 3% pour le dernier
trimestres alors nous évidemment on
aimerait bien que ça nous arrive sauf
que pour la Chine est bien c'est
beaucoup plus bas que d'ordinaire
Gautier c'est la politique même de chez
Jinping qui est en cause les déboires de
ce zéro covid
oui alors franchement je crois qu'on
peut ne pas être d'accord avec ce que
dit numéro un chinois quand il dit enfin
il faut être sérieux qui agit de la
sorte pour préserver la population bon
je crois qu'il y a vraiment pas
clairement la même le même respect de
l'individu en République populaire de
Chine en revanche ce il y a une
contradiction à laquelle sizing ping est
confronté c'est que d'un côté si vous
voulez il dit que le parti doit à
nouveau tout contrôler pour une simple
et bonne raison c'est que il a la peur
non pas d'une influence étrangère
américaine tout ce que vous voulez d'une
influence culturelle non il a peur que
non seulement les élites chinoises mais
que le peuple la population chinoise
finalement tombe dans une dérive molle
et se laisse aller donc il faut
redresser la barre de ce côté là mais
avec une contradiction énorme c'est que
si vous stoppez
l'initiative privée et bien du coup les
problèmes économiques se poursuivent et
donc il est pris entre les deux et c'est
vrai que sa politique de zéro covid a
été un frein simplement moi je me
demande si elle a pas été une manière
aussi de contrôler ou de tirer par les
rênes un certain nombre d'activités qui
étaient très on va dire bénéfique ou
prolixe même et qui ont été qui
pouvaient être soupçonné d'être en
quelque sorte des expressions de
déviance subversive subversive et de
déviance par rapport à la doxa du du
numéro 1 et du parti ah vous êtes
impressionné par la démonstration de
puissance chinoise au contraire par sa
capacité à s'affaiblir elle-même par ce
type de décision et de fonctionnement il
faut bien le dire rigide vu de
l'extérieur alors moi je suis
impressionné par rien Raphaël mais je
suis tout simplement quand je vois
l'esthétique la pure esthétique des
images qui nous viennent de ce de ce
congrès de ce 20e congrès j'ai je
repense à celle qui sont pas si
lointaines de celle du congrès du du PCS
du Parti communiste de l'Union
soviétique donc tout ça ça s'est terminé
en 1991 mais aujourd'hui on est il y a
des similitudes je trouve assez
intéressantes entre
l'ajustement la façon qu'à
si comme Gauthier vient de le dire de se
montrer en chef en chef du parti parce
qu'il est avant tout un homme du parti
c'est tout ce qui n'existe plus en URSS
mais ce qui existe tout le temps et puis
c'est au moment où il a parlé je crois
de la réunification souhaitable avec
Taïwan qu'il a été le plus applaudit ça
a été vraiment le moment je dirais
émotion de de de de tout son discours et
là on peut faire un parallèle quand même
avec la Russie poste soviétique avec
Vladimir Poutine qui quand il évoque la
Crimée en 2014 était également lui
applaudi par tout le monde y compris par
ce qui était encore des opposants du
régime à l'époque même si aujourd'hui il
n'y en a plus donc il y a des
similitudes il y a aussi cette la même
indifférence de Chi et de Poutine pour
les souffrances de leur peuple si on
vient de dire par rapport au covid
Vladimir Poutine quand il y a quelques
jours à Astana il dit une conférence de
presse que c'est quand même embêtant ce
qui se passe
mais quand il dit c'est il parle de la
guerre il pense pas le mot donc c'est
quand même inquiétant mais si on la
faisait pas ça serait pire donc il parle
de la guerre c'est-à-dire il a le plus
profond de mépris pour les dizaines de
milliers de citoyens russes qui ont été
perdus au combat
ça c'est moi ça me frappe ça pour le
coup cette similitude vous le disiez en
tout cas les applaudissements les plus
nourris ils ont salué son opposition
renouvelée à l'indépendance de Taïwan
écouté
la résolution de la question de Taïwan
et l'affaire du peuple chinois lui-même
et elle doit être résolue par le peuple
chinois seul nous
œuvrerons avec la plus grande sincérité
et les plus grands efforts pour une
réunification pacifique de Taïwan mais
nous ne renoncerons jamais
au recours à la
forcements nourri le signe que sur ce
point Taïwan Gauthier il n'y a pas
d'alternative comme vient de le dirham
côté chinois à la politique d'annexion
finalement proposée par chidin
sans doute que non mais les événements
qui sont produits qui se produisent
toujours en Ukraine et avec la Russie
donne à réfléchir c'est à dire que si
j'ai une pink se disait Poutine nous
fait un test pratique si la chose est
réglande une semaine comme le le
présenter le pouvoir rus et bien ça peut
être une incitation à voir comment on
peut tester à nouveau les États-Unis
mais comme l'Occident n'en a cure et il
se mêlera pas de ça là il y a deux
constatations la première c'est que
l'Occident s'en mêle on peut trouver
moult critique mais il s'en mêlent et
deuxièmement c'est que la Russie est
incapable de conquérir l'Ukraine que ça
soit en une semaine en deux en trois en
quatre et là alors d'un côté ça lui pose
des questions et c'est une pink de
l'autre c'est aussi une manière de
conforter de le conforter dans son idée
que si il arrivait à bâtir un monde
multipolaire ça serait quand même avec
la Chine tout en haut c'est-à-dire qu'on
voudrait bien que certains s'amusent
entre en dessous mais que ce serait
quand même la la oui la l'expression
d'un impérialisme chinois il prononcera
pas le le terme en fait c'est ça donc
mais juste d'un mot je reviens sur ce
qu'on a entendu c'est quand même pour
ceux qui seraient capables on disait de
s'enthousiasme mais c'est quand même
d'une pauvreté terrible ce qu'on entend
c'est c'est pour tout le monde dit mon
dieu c'est Shein pink il a dit c'est
formidable je voudrais juste chef mais
oui mais il est quand même vous savez il
y a les pensées de Jean Ping donc on dit
qu'elle sont particulièrement
importantes j'en ai relevé une et
d'entendit pardon oui qu'elles vont être
inscrites peut-être dans la Constitution
et enseigner aux élèves de ce congrès
voilà et enseigner aux écoliers il dit
par exemple j'aime le sport et
l'adaptation et mon sport préféré faire
de l'exercice permet de rester en forme
et en bonne santé et permet aussi de
travailler plus efficacement je pense
que nous devons trouver un équilibre
entre travailler détente cela peut nous
permettre de rester énergique et nous
aider à mieux faire notre travail bon
alors si on sait qu'en en Chine il y a
quand même des problèmes de cadence
infernale voilà ce que c'est que la
pensée du Grand Timonier aujourd'hui
voilà quoi ça parle pour soi Anne
vraiment en amour parce qu'on arrive à
la fin non non je vous en prie mais vous
pensez vous que les événements
Ukrainiens vont inspirer la prudence à
Chili et ils inspirent déjà la il est
clair que la Chine qui excelle dans
l'observation et la non-implication
historique de la Chine ne s'implique
jamais militairement nulle part
à conséquence et que bien sûr que si a
entendu ce que Joe Bayern dit quand il
dit que il ne déplora pas de troupes en
confrontation directe avec les meilleurs
Poutine et qu'il ne veut pas aller vers
une troisième guerre mondiale mais quid
de la Chine merci ce sera la fin ah on
vous retrouve dès votre retour